on reparle de jeremstar puisqu'il va
sortir sur la sphère du jeune gay et il
s'est confié au parisien jean cyril
alors il a parlé un peu de la faire je
pars à la rappeler c'était une sombre
histoire de baduel
et il parle de vous série v et jacques
toubon alors alors on rappelle à faire
sauter les garçons mineurs qui se sont
plaints d'agression sexuelle lors de
soirées passées en compagnie du blogueur
et de pascal coordonna alias baby beel
et jeremstar avait publié un communiqué
où il annonçait ce dso de la ce de ce
deal à et bon voilà les royaux sur la
noyée par les jeremstar serait écarté de
s'éviter une fera plus partie de des
terriens du dimanche alors autour
d'interviews c'est vrai qu'il parle de
moi oui mais parisien pas ses pattes
c'est pas très sain il a déclaré qu'il
était déçu et je vais lui répondre ce
soir regardé par apa le bloggeur
jeremstar est de retour et il a décidé
de régler ses comptes
après une année 2010 hui très compliqué
le jeune homme connu pour ses interviews
de célébrités de la télé réalité dans sa
baignoire qui avait obtenu une place de
chroniqueur dans l'émission les terriens
du dimanche sur ces 8 avait vu sa
carrière s'arrêter net suite à des
accusations dacquois babe un autre
blogueur sur internet
à l'époque des vidéos compromettantes de
lui avait été dévoilée sur les réseaux
sociaux avant d'être accusé quelques
jours plus tard d'être lié avec son ami
pascal cardona alias baby beel à
l'organisation de soirées douteuses s'il
n'a pas été condamné par la justice
cette histoire avait fait grand bruit et
ses 8 avait à l'époque pris la décision
de le suspendre temporairement de
l'antenne aujourd'hui jeremstar est de
retour avec un livre pour présenter sa
vérité et c'est dans le parisien qu'il a
décidé de régler ses comptes notamment
avec cyril hanouna il lui reproche de
l'avoir invité sur son plateau en lui
faisant croire à un retour sur ces huit
déception d'avoir j'ai le sentiment
était pour un pantin déception de
m'avoir fait croire voilà qu'il allait
m'aider à me faire revenir sur ces 8
alors qu'au final sur son plateau je me
suis rendu compte que
ça n'avait pas eu lieu que j'étais un
petit peu le dindon de la partie à
l'époque le groupe canal n'avait pas vue
d'un très bon oeil qui lie s'exprimer
sur tmc
alors qu'il avait été invité à le faire
à plusieurs reprises sur ces 8 la chaîne
qui lui avaient fait confiance
alors on va pas faire deux heures là
dessus on va faire une minute je vais
répondre à jeremstar qui trompe
complètement jeu mais bon je l'aimé bien
en plus il était venu ici qu'un envie
qu'on lui avait proposé de participer à
l'émission de valérie bénaïm il a dit
non il a dit que c'était pas c'est bien
pour lui je crois valérie pouvais me
confirme la baisse
oui c'était pas mon époque c'était
julien mais sérieusement c'était la
réponse qu'ils avaient fait il ya eu des
pratiques assez bien pour lui donc voilà
deux qui redirige schirrhein stars et
moi je dirai toujours toute la vérité
sache qu'on a essayé de te faire revenir
sur la chaîne la chaîne ne voulait pas
que toi et je te le dis ils se sont
servis mine de rien comme moi je dis
toujours toute la vérité comme un petit
peu france télévisions avec tex ils sont
servis de ça pour te dégager
voilà je te dis la vérité et sur dia bâ
tiens ça tombe bien puisque on les met
pas dans l'émission de thierry qu'on
trouvait qu'il n'avait rien à y faire
eh ben c'est très bien comme ça on va le
sortir et donc c'est pas la peine cyril
de le reprendre donc merci on m'a
demandé gentiment de ne pas te reprendre
au sein de nos émissions ont reçu
toujours toute la vérité et je n'étais
pas ton producteur c'est thierry
ardisson que j'aime beaucoup thierry et
stéphane simon
s'il avait voulu garder c'est à eux
d'aller voir caler la chaîne trt et deux
se battent pour toi j'ai essayé de te
mettre chez valérie boyer nous dit voilà
comme ça on avait une latitude peut être
maître chez lui à courber apparemment ce
n'était pas assez bien pour toi voilà
donc on te dira toujours toute la vérité
nous et voilà je te le dis c'est la
chaîne qui voulait pas de toit sur ces
mythes et voilà il voit là ils tuent
correspondait pas apparemment à ce
qu'ils voulaient mais nous on aurait
bien pris avec nous chez julien koré
parce que on monte on t'aimait bien
voilà je pense fin du débat